4e secondaire cours d'histoire du québec
et du canada
le professeur raymond bédard prend les
devants 2 1 quand même à peu près 150
mais l'enfant qui ont été retirés de
leur famille ils profitent de
l'actualité pour initier ses élèves un
des chapitres les plus douloureux de
l'histoire des autochtones au canada
mais nous les prolos on connaît pas tout
le temps alors on découvre parfois avec
un peu d'eau rare qui s'est passé dans
les pensionnats et pas question
d'épargner les jeunes il leur explique
ce qui est arrivé et pourquoi moi quand
j'ai commencé dans l'enseignement il ya
plus de 30 ans
j'étais au courant de ce n'est pas une
autochtone ou très peu puis lors là ça
prend une ampleur importante avec les
découvertes puis la commission enquête
maintenant on se dit il faudrait
véritablement mieux connaître cette
réalité là les réalités c'est qu'au
québec les pensionnats autochtones sont
carrément pulte et du programme
d'histoire et les manuels scolaires en
disent peu sinon quelques phrases
raymond bédard confirme que cela va
changer dès l'an prochain mais qu'il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin au delà de
la correction du programme il faut aussi
ken bonne formation au niveau des
enseignants pour qu'ils soient mieux
informés eux aussi s'assurer qu'il
puisse bien transmettre le contexte dans
lequel les premières nations ont évolué
depuis la création de réserves et la loi
sur les indiens ou 19e siècle à 15 ans
ces élèves ignorait que les premières
nations où étaient soumises à ce qui est
aujourd'hui qualifié de génocide
culturel
moi je ne savais pas
je n'ai pas au courant de ce m j'avais
pas casser des basses et l'iman tout un
morceau d'histoire et de l'aveu même des
jeunes les cours ne reflètent pas les
temps modernes
le problème avec une petite partie de
nos cours d'histoire c'est qu'on a pas
les autochtones c'est tout le temps
c'est tout le temps je me avec les
européens c'est tout le temps l'histoire
des européens avec les autochtones s'est
jamais les autochtones tout court
d'après moi on dit pas tout à fait la
vérité on dit un petit parti pour pas
qu'on ait de l'ère des méchants qui
creuse les peuples si maintenant on dit
of our église pourparlers le sort peu
baissé de l'inclure dans notre histoire
mais s'il fait qu'ils n'ont pas fait ça
me choque
on a oublié ces personnes là qui sont
morts leur enseignante isabelle dupuis
partagent leurs préoccupations depuis
des années oui ils ont raison
malheureusement c'est un sujet dont on
traite de façon partielle pour elle le
rapport sur les pensionnats où si l'on
soit il est devenu un outil
indispensable
le rapport devrait être lu par tous les
enseignants du québec ça nous donne
vraiment une perspective et ça nous
permet de comprendre ce qu'ils ont vécu
et de répondre à la fameuse question des
élèves mais pourquoi les autochtones il
scanne permet d'aller au-delà du
folklore que véhicule encore aujourd'hui
les manuels scolaires on voit pas ce que
leurs impressions des choses quand on
est arrivé on veut pas non plus toute la
signification qui cueillons russian
développer de notes rapides
tout ce qui était imposé en vigueur qui
écrivent l'histoire et voilà que c'est à
leur tour de constater qu'il est temps
de la corriger
et si thammarat altérer ce coup radio
canada